It's Bob's first day to walk alone in 26 years.
His therapists at Good Shepherd Rehabilitation Center are measuring Emilio...
...and adjusting a high-tech suit.
That suit will lift him out of his wheelchair and prompt his legs to move.
The hardware is an Ekso bionic exoskeleton:...
...a wearable robot.
When a therapist pushes the button, the Ekso guides the patient forward and up.
Then these battery-powered motors take over like muscles, encouraging the legs to move.
Russ Angold is the co-founder of Ekso Bionics.
They still bear their own weight on their bone structure.
The Ekso just provides the support and the ability to move.
Kevin Oldt is an Ekso success story.
He says Ekso brings more than physical changes.
When you put hope into somebody that lost hope,...
...it changes their whole way of living and life...
...a hundred percent.